but boy I've just heard yes hold on
where are you going
she wants to see him now
in all of King's Landing is a known to
take my side
the realm
do you know what the realm is
it's the Thousand Blades of aegon's
enemies a story we agreed to tell each
other over and over till we forget that
it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another Game of Thrones in
House of the Dragon update video in this
video we will be looking at all of the
new official photos from this Sunday's
episode of House of the Dragon over the
last few days HBO has released a number
of new videos and photos that give us a
glimpse of what will be happening in
this next episode as you all know this
new episode will have many new actors
since we are now jumping ahead roughly a
decade into the story one of the major
differences from the last episode is
Damon Targaryen is now married to Lady
Lena valerion we saw Damon and Lady Lena
on the Dance Floor during rhaenyra in
sir lanor's wedding not only is Damon
now married again but he's also a father
now as well lady Elena valerion in Damon
will now have twin daughters named Bayla
in Reina Targaryen there's a number of
different new high definition photos of
their family another thing some of you
might not know is Damon will no longer
be living in Westeros either him and his
new family will be living over an essos
or pentos to be exact while they're
there they will be living inside the
magister's mans right outside of the
city walls in George RR Martin's novel
we learned the main reason why Damon and
his family leave Westeros for essos is
because Damon knows his brother viserys
would not be happy with the fact that he
got remarried after Damon had several
victories in the stepstones which we saw
in the earlier episode they now see him
as an ally who they might need again
Damon and his wife lady Lena valerion
don't always like staying in one
location either we might see them flying
to different locations over on essos but
as soon as they learned she will be
having another baby they will eventually
go back to pentos if they do follow
George RR Martin's novel Damon and Lady
Lena will stay there for another half a
year before heading back to his wife's
home on driftmark another very
noticeable difference from last week's
episode will be the introduction of
rhaenyra's sons they are jacaris Luke
Aries and Joffrey valerion like I said
in my last video one of the major
conflicts in this new episode will be
the legitimacy of her sons it's not
going to be hard to see that rhaenyra's
Sons were not fathered by her husband
sir Lenor valerion as you can see a much
older actor will be stepping in for this
character as well now as you can imagine
one of the main reasons why rhaenyra's
illegitimate Sons make Allison so angry
is the fact that they are in the line of
succession before her own sons aegon in
amond now since renera's Sons do have
her husband's valerion name they're
actually legitimate until someone brings
forward some evidence saying otherwise
as of right now the line of succession
goes raniera then her son's jacaris Lou
carries and then Joffrey whenever
rhaenyra has a new son it leaves
Alison's sons aegon and aemon further
and further down the line behind them
this has to be making her furious
considering the fact that she knows
their bastards rhaenyra and Allison's
growing hatred for each other will fall
onto their sons as well we get a glimpse
of this in the new photos and videos
also here we see Allison's sons in the
yard sword fighting with rhaenyra sons
while sir Kristen and Sir Harwin watch
over them this must be very awkward
first for Kristen Cole and Sir Harwin
considering how we all know sir Kristen
wanted to run away with renero not only
did she decline his offer but she began
having all of these Sons by someone else
it will become very obvious that sir
Harwin fathered these children instead
of renera's actual husband sir lanor
valerion now that sir Kristen Cole is in
the service of Alison Hightower he will
most likely help her expose the Scandal
this might have something to do with why
we see sir Kristen and Sir Harwin
fighting each other in the video one of
them most likely said something to the
other leading to this fight in the yard
it will only further divide the sides of
the blacks and the greens even more now
in a few of these other photos we also
see viserys and Allison's second born
son Amon Targaryen it looks like this is
him shortly after he tried to mount the
dragon dream fire we've also seen
glimpses of that in HBO's official video
In the next photo does look like his
mother Alo sent might be giving him some
words of encouragement aemon will not be
able to mount the dragon dream fire but
he will end up getting something much
better now if you have seen some of
HBO's other photos and videos then you
know aemond will eventually lose his eye
during a fight with renera's sons
afterwards he will be known as aemond
one eye Targaryen and I'm really looking
forward to seeing this older version of
amond I have a feeling he will be one of
my favorites from the show in another
photo Allison is also seen with her
daughter Helena Targaryen now before I
do go I also want to let you hear my
video I made about rhaenyra and lenor's
wedding I actually did upload this video
already but after it was flagged I did
take it back down to fix it after a few
days went by I thought about just
deleting the video but since I did work
on it for an entire day I don't want to
throw it away after all of that work so
I thought I would just shove it in here
at the end of this video so some of you
can still see it if you're interested in
my thoughts on the wedding let me know
what you thought about everything down
below now now let's get into the next
video
now this wedding was actually set in
Motion in the last episode when rainer's
father viserys no longer gave her the
option of finding her own husband after
allegations were made about rhaenyra in
Damon's incestuous relationship viserys
figured he better find his daughter a
husband soon otherwise she might not
only ruin her name but also the
likelihood of her finding a worthy
Suitor although viserys was very angry
with his daughter this did work out for
him because now he could find her a good
husband himself and since he decided on
Sir Lenor valerion this would also
resurrect his relationship with the sea
snake not only is he incredibly wealthy
but he also has the largest Fleet
Westeros has ever seen not to mention
the sea snake also has dragons on his
side rhaenyra's Future Husband sir Lenor
rides on the dragon sea smoke the same
one who defended Damon during his battle
against the crab feeder the sea snake's
wife rhaenys Targaryen rides on the
dragon melees and their daughter lady
Lena valerion now has the largest living
dragon in Westeros the massive she
Dragon Veigar so as you can see house
valerion is someone viserys will one on
his side having his daughter rhaenyra
Mary sir lanor was the best available
option now viserys wasn't the only one
who would benefit from this marriage
Alliance either the fact that sir lanor
as a gay man also allows for him and
ranero to still do their own thing after
meeting before the wedding ceremony
rhaenyra and Sir lanor made a deal with
one another they agreed that they would
marry each other for the alliance but
they would still have their own fun
outside of the marriage allowing
themselves to find love elsewhere so
with all of that being said how could
any of this go wrong well on the day the
wedding celebrations began it opened up
with the welcoming Feast it started with
us seeing some of the major houses of
Westeros entering the Great Hall of the
red key one of the very first things we
immediately notice is Allison Hightower
was absent from this ceremony it does
make me wonder why was Alison so late to
the feast as we all know in the last
episode her father gave her advice about
about what to do after he was gone he
reminded her that viserys will die soon
and when he does she must have aegon
ready for the Iron Throne otherwise they
will never actually be safe so long as
renera sees them as a threat to her
inheritance so far we have seen Allison
stand by reniro's side but after she
found out her best friend lied right to
her face it changed everything it now
seems Allison is open to the idea of
having her son aegon sit on the Iron
Throne regardless if ranera still is her
father's Heir while Alison was absent
from the wedding Feast I couldn't help
but wonder if she was making
arrangements for her and her son's
future we will see Alison has a whole
new Vibe once she enters the great hall
now before we get into all of that house
valerion makes one hell of an entrance
into the Great Hall themselves their
swaggerous felt throughout as every eye
in the entire Hall directs its gaze onto
them I mean after all soreline or
valerion is the man of the hour sir
Kristen Cole watches from afar the man
looks as if he has a Valerian steel
dagger shoved in his heart we then see
Damon Targaryen roll up in there with
the Swagger of a thousand Oberon
martells this isn't even his wedding and
we're not even sure if he was actually
invited Yeti walks into the Great Hall
as if he owns the joint viserys is
visibly upset he must be wondering if
Damon murdered his wife so he could come
right back to the city now viserys
absolutely wants to say something to
Damon but he also doesn't want to make a
scene in front of everyone and ruin the
wedding remember viserys does worry
about what everyone else thinks so he
begrudgingly has someone grab Damon a
seat at the high table once again Damon
does get his welcome home but this time
it's not with open arms the big-ass
smile on Damon's face says I know you
don't want me here but everyone in this
Great Hall knows you won't say a damn
thing about it either then we see the
honor of house valerion begin viserys is
right in the middle of giving this
amazing speech when it suddenly
interrupted by his wonderful loving wife
Alison Hightower now I must say
Allison's arrival was very reminiscent
of Cersei Lannister's coronation Allison
was without a doubt making a statement
for one she shows up in our green dress
making it known to everyone in the room
she stands with her own house Hightower
remember she was always seen wearing the
red and black of Faust Targaryen after
she married viserys after feeling
betrayed by her best friend ranera and
given the advice of her father Serrato
Allison has now officially severed ties
from House Targaryen The Local and
viserys's face says it all he felt
slighted once again yet like with
Damon's arrival he's not going to make
an ass out of himself in front of all
the watchful and judgmental eyes in the
room now before she reaches the Deus
Allison flashes a looker family's way
letting them know her Allegiance is with
them now what we hear Lara strong say
might have been a little heavy-handed
beacon on the high tower
do you know what color it glows when Old
Town calls its Banners To War
green
I don't think they needed him to say
this to the audience I think it was
already understood but maybe that's only
me everyone there feels a noticeable
difference with Allison once she reaches
the high table viserys and even rhaenera
look unsettled by this shift in
Allison's Behavior the days of Allison
having faith in her King and husband as
well as her friend and stepdaughter are
now gone it makes for a wonderful scene
let the games begin ladies and gentlemen
we barely see the end of the bride's
first dance when Ellison suddenly and
abruptly leaves her seat she doesn't
look at viserys and say excuse me she
does it anyway the new hand of the king
and even the sea snake notice and watch
in silence as she leaves it's very
obvious Alice and his feeling some type
of way we then see her walk over to be
with her family she's reminded that old
town does stand with her and this is the
first time we've seen her smile all
night it lets us know that it's her
family that does make her feel happy and
welcome then Damon is suddenly ambushed
by Sir Gerald Royce of of runestone he's
there to make sure that Damon is held
accountable for his wife's sudden death
as you can imagine Damon doesn't find
this amusing or interesting to say the
least his wife is already a fleeting
memory he wishes to forget sir Gerald is
a bold man by making accusations against
the king's brother right in the middle
of his daughter's wedding ceremony if it
were up to Damon I'm not sure that sir
Gerald would make it out of the city
alive on the other hand however Damon
was glad he was there it was a good
opportunity for Damon to discuss his
inheritance since lady Royce was his
wife and they had no heirs Damon stands
to inherit all of runestone something he
doesn't tend to receive after the seven
days of wedding festivities in The
Following episode we should see Damon
arrive on his Dragon koraxis ready to
gain his new fortunes my guess is house
Royce will not hand over everything to
Damon so easily but we shall see Damon
then sets his sights on lady Lena
valerion the daughter of the sea snake
and rhaenys as Damon is finding himself
a new wife we also see Joffrey loudmouth
decipher the local and Sir Kristen
Cole's face he believes he knows why sir
Kristen can't take his eyes off the new
bride he also thinks he can use that
information against renera if she were
ever to say anything about Sir lanor and
Joffrey's relationship well Joffrey's
interest in sir Kristen's love life will
come back the bite him in the ass later
on he immediately goes up the sir
Kristen and reveals he knows about his
Dirty Little Secret not only that but he
even threatens him with the information
as this is happening we see the real
reason why Damon went on to the dance
floor he eventually finds his way over
to renera who was dancing with sir
Harwin now this is interesting because
we will see rhaenyra and Sir harwin's
relationship go to the next level very
soon this innocent dancing sets in
motion events that will lead to all
kinds of issues with rhaenyra's rights
to the Iron Throne as soon as Damon has
renera alone he lets her know her future
with sir Lenor will not be a fun one
although Lenor is a good man in a fine
night he won't make for a great husband
that's when rhaenyra calls his bluff she
says if you really want me then take me
to Dragonstone now and make me your wife
if you really want me that bad don't let
anything get in your way I do Wonder did
renera actually want him to do this or
was she only saying it out of anger now
before Damon's able to answer the
dancing suddenly stops as everyone
gathers around sir Kristen Cole who's
Gone full Greg Oracle again on lenor's
lover Joffrey loudmouth
[Applause]
well Joffrey certainly won't be making
any more threats to Sir Kristen Cole
that's for sure he literally beat this
man to death giving us those red wedding
Vibes now you have to wonder was he
justified did Joffrey actually deserve
this based on what he had done or said I
actually don't think so now he did make
threats sure but I still don't think
that gives a kingsguard member the right
to execute him like this especially in
the middle of Rainier wedding
celebrations although I did not like
Joffrey and I'm not even mad at sir
Kristen for doing it I still think he
went over the line either way now don't
get me wrong it made for one hell of a
scene viserys is so upset with what
happened he has rhaenyra and Lenor get
married anyway right away the seven days
of celebrating this wonderful Union are
now over the marriage and Alliance must
move forward right there in the middle
of the bloody Hall renera and lanor join
houses then in what might be the worst
scene of the episode sir Kristen goes
outside to the godswood with his dagger
in hand ready to end it all before
anything happens Allison does stop him
before he's able to go through with it
now although we don't see it this is
when Alison will have sir Kristen join
her service now he will be her guard
moving forward this is gonna sever their
relationship with rhaenyra even more we
have seen this in other official photos
and videos from HBO after this Allison
answer Kristen Cole will join forces
against renera they will never look at
her the same again as rhaenyra and
cerlenor wed in the Great Hall viserys
collapses onto the floor it's as if this
day wasn't bad enough everyone is
reminded of the fact that viserys's
health is failing although it does seem
like he's been dying since the very
first episode he will somehow hang on
for another decade as his body continues
to decompose right before our very eyes
now in the final shot of this episode we
see a rat emerge onto the blood soak
floor this is foreshadowing an event
that involves characters known as blood
and cheese now as much as I want to go
into what that event is all about I
don't want to ruin it for you either
let's just say when that scene finally
does happen it will go down as one of
the moments of the show will be
remembered for I will leave it at that
for now like I was saying at the
beginning of this video what happened at
the wedding will have an effect on every
individual who was there it's set in
motion so many things like Allison and
Sir Kristen joining forces Damon
marrying lady Elena renera and Sir
Harwin and so much more if you haven't
seen my last video about the episode 6
trailer that video will show you some of
the aftermath from this wedding I would
highly recommend watching that as well
now hopefully most of you are subscribed
already because you will be the first to
know whenever I release the rest of my
videos this week I still have several
more videos heading your way before the
next episode airs let me know what all
of you thought about this wedding down
below so many different things were
happening so I'm interested in hearing
what you have to say about them as
always I want to thank all of you for
watching this video I hope you all have
a great day I will see you again very
soon
bye
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign